on connait c'est marc meneau à
saint-pierre le sous vézelay bernard
loiseau à saulieu désormais il faudra
compter avec jean paul grappe il a créé
des émules outre atlantique ce chef
cuisinier dijonnais est le meilleur
ambassadeur de la gastronomie
bourguignonne au québec
une enseigne inattendue dans les rues de
montréal la brioche lyonnais
l'établissement est tenu par deux
français qui la font un ancien chez
bocuse et jean paul grappe dijonnais
d'origine qui a travaillé à la bonne
auberge mais aussi à lyon chez la mère
vite et il était parti pour l'exposition
de montréal et il est finalement resté
au canada jean paul grappe était certes
un peu inquiet au départ mais
aujourd'hui il ne regrette pas son
aventure
le canada lé d'amendé québec plus
particulièrement à la consonance
francophone dont on est un petit peu
chez nous et les gens sont très
accueillants ici évidemment dans notre
métier il ya une très grosse évolution
en arrivant de france évidemment on un
petit peu dépaysé mons met tout de suite
dans le bain je pense ça coeur reste
très française et même une partie de ses
approvisionnements
mais le canada lui offre aussi
d'immenses possibilités pour enrichir
ses menus la france évidemment connais
pas les gibiers poissons que nous avons
ici parce que je voudrais pas vous
donner l'eau à la bouche mais si c'est
le pays le plus merveilleux pour la
chasse et la pêche
le mar par exemple pain au maïs avec les
homards du canada sont les meilleurs au
monde en france je préfère de parti-pris
mali roman de mauritanie sont très durs
parce qu'ils vivent en eau chaude elle
est meilleure pour moi au monde viennent
du canada plus particulièrement des îles
de la madeleine et ils sont très très
très recherchés
les restaurateurs canadiens de leur côté
admis à la cuisine française mais ils
font aussi preuve de rien d'ironie à
l'égard de certaines tendances
contemporaines
l'accusée une princesse une des grandes
cuisines com
les cuisines italiennes et chinoises
que j'apprécie beaucoup ainsi des
grandes réussites et non plus élu vous
même acheté 100 lits je vais garder ça
ne suis pas toujours d'accord avec lui
c'est une cuisine qui disent la cuisine
d'aujourd'hui une cuisine légère ces
régions on n'a pas tellement la douleur
pouvoir et une cuisine c'est en mange
bien on allait manger et je trouve ça
devient tellement léger que les
assiettes sans quasiment vide vous avez
très peu ici un dc nous on aime bien
manger en
négociation mais c'est un peu de
fantaisie si vous voulez c'est réglé
s'il a fait d'accord mais si on passe
les bras dans mango
entre les filles du roy la brioche
lyonnaise et bien d'autres les canadiens
comme les visiteurs de passage ou en
tout cas sans difficulté de quoi
satisfaire leur goût gastronomique au
québec